today we're going to be talking about
collecting data with text messaging we
believe that text messaging is a
low-cost simple and effective way to
collect data from almost anyone in the
world and there are a few reasons why
did you know that by 2020 more than
ninety percent of the world's population
over age six will have a cellphone and
that even today more people have cell
phones than toilets and 350 billion text
messages are sent every month so we
think that text messaging should be a
part of your data collection tool kit
and we think that you should consider
using rapid pro to design messaging
workflows and collect this data um a
little bit about us first you may know
me from cactus but I am recently a
cactus alum as of Monday i started at
trans look which is a public
transportation technology company down
the road but during the previous four
years at cactus among other things i
built text messaging applications with
rapid Prohm without for that have been
used in countries around the world to
collect data and provide services and
just real quickly I'm Erin Malini I am a
current cactus group developer if you're
not familiar with cactus group we are a
web firm in Durham North Carolina
working mostly with python and django
I've been a developer for about 12 years
and I've been at cactus for about a year
and a half I've worked on different
rabbit trail related projects like the
track pro the data visualization tool
which I'll be talking about later today
in the community portal we didn't as
cactus we did not build rapid pro but we
do offer it as a software as a service
option and promote it because we find it
to be such an excellent tool for SMS
like that oops so to get started here's
a quick definition of what rapid pro is
in case you haven't heard of it before
at its core rapid pro is a tool for
creating interactive messaging systems
you can use it to create messaging
workflows and collect analyze and
categorize input from users users
participate via SMS or other messaging
channels and they move through the flow
according to the logic that you
9 you can view or download the data that
you collect or you can export it via the
API to have custom processing or
integrate with an external system most
importantly you don't have to be a
programmer to use rapid pro the GUI
allows anyone to create complex
workflows um and you can immediately
start collecting data from users but
because it is open source and it has a
great API it is good for development too
or maybe start without development and
added on later um alright so we are
going to talk about four main topics
today um SMS to how it is used today and
why we think that H that you should use
it for data collection then I will talk
about the high-level components of rapid
pro and we'll dive into the survey that
you took today to show you more of how
it was built and she'll talk about the
data API that you can use to extract
data for analysis and external
applications um SMS has been around for
a while and a lot has changed in that
time we have a lot of other
communication options like email and
Twitter and Facebook and instant
messaging apps like whatsapp but
globally SMS is still the number one
tool used to access information and this
is because it is not reliant on things
like constant network access or speed
it's available on all operating systems
Android iOS and even basic phones there
is no need for users to install another
app or create another account or learn a
new interface to use your product
sometimes it seems like everyone at
least in the US has a computer and a
smartphone but this isn't necessarily
the case even though more than ninety
percent of the people in the u.s. own a
cell phone only some sixty-five percent
own smartphones and in some areas low
network coverage and poverty can push
that number lower as well as many places
outside the US don't have as much access
to smartphones furthermore alternatives
like Twitter snapchat whatsapp tend to
reach different segments of the
population um in contrast SMS covers a
broad group of demographics and from a
business standpoint as
a mess is pretty inexpensive to
implement the technical needs are well
defined there is no visual you I to
create and many users already know how
to use the product and can use it from
wherever they are at SMS is used for
things like surveys like user
satisfaction surveys after they've used
a product or values questionnaires to
gauge their political interests it
powers consumer services like
prescription refill or the next time
that the bus will arrive at the stop
that you're at um it can be used to
power customer service lines or allow
users to send in questions and feedback
I'm sure you can think of other uses um
we have a couple of specific examples um
SMS has been used to improve health care
in various countries including Rwanda
community health care workers send in
data about maternal milestones or maybe
measurements of early childhood growth
data over the course of time as I see
patients centralized aid organizations
aggregate and analyze this information
and with it they can determine what they
can track trends i can track changes and
they can see which parts of the country
may be in need of additional programs to
address healthcare issues text messaging
is used domestically and internationally
for education applications it can be
used to say um track information about
class sizes and tendons especially over
a large or remote region research has
also also shown that text message
reminders can be used to nudge students
in the right direction on and stay on
track when applying to college at a very
low cost per student um the last example
give you today is in Libya a North
African country which is experiencing a
lot of political turmoil cactus is proud
to have helped implement SMS voter
registration there because traveling to
voter registration centers can be
difficult or dangerous but most people
have or have access to a phone that's
equipped with text messaging at home
also people don't have to worry about
whether changes will get lost or delayed
because they can check them immediately
and additionally officials and even the
public can monitor progress with a
real-time dashboard which is pretty cool
so several of
aforementioned examples are powered by
rapid Pro which like I mentioned is a
tool to design applications and services
that connect with users via text
messaging UNICEF is a large
international aid organization that
sponsored the creation of rapid pro to
address three key problems that they saw
over and over again when building text
message applications and services first
they wanted to be able to iterate and
validate their ideas before investing in
custom software development they didn't
want to have to build from the ground up
with their whole messaging
infrastructure for each project second
they wanted to create canonical tools
for all the infrastructure that SMS
applications typically need but they
also wanted an API where the data could
be retrieved and individual developers
for individual projects could pull out
that data and use it as needed for a
variety of applications finally they
wanted to be able to scale successful
projects from you know small pilot to
maybe thousands or millions of users
rapid Pro is easy to use easy to get
started and with but powerful enough to
do that and it's open source so if you
need changes or have custom architecture
needs um then you can deploy it yourself
and make the changes that you need rapid
protects messaging or even one
communication channel you can maintain a
whole suite of channels so that you can
connect with individual users on
whichever channel works best for them
you can connect with a phone gateway to
nori interface with phone network
operators and many of these services
like twilio also offer um interactive
voice response which is the technology
used to power interactive helplines like
if you call time warner cable and you
can run your flows over that as well you
can send messages via social media sites
like Twitter and Facebook telegram and
more and if all else fails there's an
API to connect external services as to
get started quickly you might consider
downloading the Android app that the
Creator is made so that you can turn
your own phone into an SMS gateway or
use Twitter so that you can test flows
on your own computer for free
um okay so rapid pro has a gui-based
flow editor that allows you to design
complex or closed with no need for
software developer and you can iterate
quickly and validate your ideas and
develop the right thing for your
audience a flow is made up of a series
of actions rules and connections it's
the first approximation you could think
of it as a survey and actions our
operations taken by the system like
sending a message to the user or calling
an external API rules are logical tests
that are performed against the users
current state in the flow in a survey
you would want to categorize user input
into groups like say healthy patients
and unhealthy patients finally
connections join actions with rules we
might want to take different actions for
healthy patients versus unwell ones but
flows are more than just surveys the
flow editor is really like a mini
language and it allows you to perform
any actions um and do many things and
Aaron will dive into that in a few
minutes so to help you understand your
data um ah yes you'll want to manage
your audience you can um upload contacts
um either individually or in bulk if you
know who people are for example you
collected numbers on a sign-up sheet but
um you can also use keyword triggers to
allow people to join your flow like you
did earlier today um and you can group
contacts you can group them into known
and existing groups like healthy and
unhealthy patients or you could rip them
into arbitrary groups we could group
patient or group users according to the
answer to what is your favorite color
without having to create groups for all
of the colors before doing this um and
you can store information on user
profiles to help you understand your
data rapid Pro offers a handful of
modest built-in analytics like the type
that you see here but chances are you're
going to have custom needs for analysis
or other things
you'll want to organize your data
differently that's where the API comes
in rapid probe how provides powerful
tools for collecting data but it remains
intentionally unah pinion ated about
what you're doing with this data so you
can use the API and get to your data and
build a custom management dashboard on
to view and analyze your results ok now
that Rebecca's taken us on an excellent
high-level overview of rapid pro let's
take a deep dive into the survey that a
lot of you took today so you walked in
the room today we didn't ask you for
your phone numbers we didn't ask you for
your Twitter handles but yet you were
able to connect with our rapid pro
instance and take a survey so how did we
start a flow without any contacts the
way we did that today was and Rebecca
mentioned this earlier was via a keyword
trigger so your flip your contacts do
not have to exist ahead of time do you
remember what your keyword trigger was
today yeah fine data um so a couple
things to think about when you're
creating your keyword trigger for your
flow you cannot include special
characters in your keyword trigger and
this keyword trigger is available for
all channels today we used it for both
channels that we have set up on our
rapid pro instance both the Twitter
channel and the SMS channel so you could
have taken the survey via either channel
the way you want to create your keyword
trigger is either from within the flow
itself so when you're inside a rapid pro
and you're editing your flow you click
on the little gear and you click Edit
and this allows you to edit modify a few
high-level things about your flow
including the name but here you can set
as many global keyword triggers as you
want and if any of these conflict with
an existing keyword trigger in your
instance of rabid pro and you click on
save it'll warn you ok I've already used
this you don't use it more than one
place you can expire your inactive
context and you can also tell your flow
while people are taking this survey I
want to ignore the keyword trigger PI
data I don't want people to get looped
back into the beginning of the flow the
other way to create a keyword trigger
is from the top level triggers menu and
rabbit pro and I'll show you that in a
second the reason that you might want to
do it this way is if you want to target
a specific group and if your contacts
already exist in rapid pro and you know
that you don't want just anybody taking
in the survey so before I dive into the
flow again there are about six different
types of triggers in rapid pro I find
three of them to be really useful and
powerful one being the keyword trigger
another being the group joined trigger
so let's say you're a sixth-grade
teacher or an school administrator and
you want your parents to be able to sign
up for SMS alerts you're going to send
them all alerts every week and maybe
occasionally an additional alert just an
informational thing they can self-select
into your instance of rapid pro and into
this group that you select here okay so
i created this group 6th grade parents
and anybody who texts the word grade 6
22 my phone number that i have set up is
going to get this response i'm going to
be added to that group you can also add
this step I haven't here but you I could
have kicked off a new flow that
collected information from them about
their student so it's pretty powerful
the other one that a third one that I
find really useful is the scheduling
flow so let's say you know by wednesday
for me wednesday afternoon folks are
going to have the information that they
need in order to take your survey and
you have those folks in your instance of
rapid pro at ease so i'm going to select
them the flow and i'm going to select
the contacts either individually or i've
already grouped them so when I grabbed
that sixth grade parents group maybe and
send them out a survey on Wednesday
afternoon and create that schedule flow
those are the three triggers I find
really powerful but let's dive back into
the flow and think about it at a really
high level so when we're building our
surveys in rapid pro your it really
boils down to these things you're
sending a message you're categorizing
the response that you get back you're
doing something and then you're
repeating that's it it's pretty simple
and if you're
thinking about it like in pseudocode
maybe you've drawn these things out
before where you've written out if L
source which case and you've thought
through all the many different responses
someone might have when they get to a
certain point in your code I know I've
written this out a million times when
I'm thinking through writing my F else
or switch case statements and rapid pro
allows as many categories as you want so
as we were building the flow questions
we asked ourselves at each step along
the way was what kind of responses can
we get what how do we want to categorize
them what do we want to do for those
categories and how do we deal with
categories outside of the responses so
when you're categorizing responses a
quick tip that you want to think about
is rapid pro is not case sensitive so
today when you were taking our survey if
you answered in all caps rapid pro did
not think you were yelling at it so when
you're categorizing your responses in
this case we asked you would you like to
take our survey as the first question
probably did want to take our survey
since you send in the keyword trigger
but we wanted to make sure so we
expected either a yes or a no answer
rapid pro allows you to really think
about yes and no through like all the
different iterations I could have kept
going but in this case I just thought
hey if the answer with a why they
probably mean yes if the answer with an
end they mean no and I came up with a
couple other responses that rapid pro
would understand and categorize and if I
scroll back here you can see we've got
my yes category and my no category and
then this other category that I didn't
build so other other is always there so
if you create a step where you have five
categories you're always going to have a
six category other how do you deal with
it well you might ask your question
again in a new way I'm sorry I didn't
understand that did you want to take the
survey yes or no you can loop back into
the original question you can accept the
other response and just move on just oh
I'm just going to assume that they meant
yes they want to take the survey or you
can do nothing I don't recommend this
one because you're just going to kind of
died in the survey
and not go anywhere um so here's our
first question again and in this case
and hard to tell because there's lots of
pipes going everywhere but the other
loops back in to the original question
just asks it again just to keep things
simple another step we might have wanted
to take here was breaking out into a new
step to create a counter and make sure
we didn't end up in an endless loop here
and continually bother this person and
asks on the same question again and
again forever and rapper loves you to
create variables like that which brings
me to expressions so rapid pro actions
and expressions let's talk about
expressions so what are they they're
basically the data of rapid fro this is
that a lot of this talk we talk through
rapid fro terminology so you may not
think of things as expressions you may
more think of them as variables and you
may not think of things as flows you may
more think of them as surveys but this
is just what rabbit protocols them so
your expressions start with an @ symbol
they are the data of your flow so in
this case if you wanted to use a flow
variable at a later part some data that
you gathered and within your flow you
would use at flow dot result name text
and use that in some fashion if you have
contact information and you want to
personalize your experience you might
want to use at contact that first name
hey Rebecca do you want to take our
survey today to really personalize the
SMS survey experience you can learn more
about rapid pro x pressions and
functions on the knowledge base but
something to keep in mind is the syntax
of all of the functions you can use in
rabbit fruit is models on Excel so a lot
of those Excel functions upper/lower
concat and then just the really basic
math functions plus minus percent all
those things are available in rapid pro
one other thing that's available when
you're categorizing your responses is
regex and we didn't use it today but it
can really be great to ensure data
integrity
what actions can you take and which ones
did we take today today we added you to
groups and rapid fro so we asked you
what state you lived in and what state
you were born in and then we broke out
here and this on the far right the split
by expression and we said do those two
states match if they do we're going to
add you to home state if they don't
we're going to add you to this other
group group state as you can see we took
two actions at those steps where we
added you to agree group as our contact
and we also sent a message to you and
again you can take as many actions as
you want at each step along the way we
also edited your contact information so
we didn't have a lot of contact
information about you when you took our
survey we had your phone number or we
had your Twitter handle depending on how
how you took our survey but at the next
last step we asked you for your name
first name just to kind of show you the
fact that you can edit a contact so we
saved that to the contact name field
finally another action we took today was
we called an external API and we've
given this talk before at a few months
ago at PyCon and this was not in the
original talk but we did this we added
this today to today's talk because we
find this really particularly powerful
for you data heads so we called an
external API and it was kind of a silly
one so we asked you what your favorite
Pokemon was if you couldn't come up with
one and you wanted us to suggest one we
use the ran between built-in function
and we knew there were 812 poking men
who do and we generated a random one for
you if you didn't know the name of your
Pokemon we went to that one and
apologies if the API call failed that
the API is randomly fails at times but
when it does we built a we built a
failure thing there which actually is
connected to the rest of the flow just
to let you know oh sorry we weren't able
to connect to it um there are so many
actions you can take him rapid pro and
you can like I said I could have taken
all of these actions at one step if I
wanted to
this is the list of actions that you can
take at each step we did do a number of
these in our flow today but there was
some like sending email that we didn't
do that are just nice to know that
they're there okay so now that we've
talked about actions and expressions
let's dig deep into expressions and talk
about calculating variables um and if
you notice we had a calculated variable
today it was really silly it was the
percentage of high data's that you
attended per year because that's a thing
um that's useful information um so we
first asked you how many years you've
been working with Python we then asked
you how many of these high data
conferences you've gone to we then um
used a expression and float up hey I
dated a text / flota years that text and
x 100 in order to repeat back to you
your percentage of pi data conferences
for years working with Python in case
you were curious so that was a
calculated variable so this is a really
silly example of a calculated variable
but they could be pretty powerful let's
say you work in a medical field and you
want to calculate the next time of an
appointment for a patient of yours and
you know the last appointment because
you called your API and you have that
data you can calculate their next
appointment as well perhaps with with
one of the built-in date functions ok so
we've talked about the survey that you
took today let's dive deep into the
rabid pro API so um accessing data via
the API is super super useful Rebecca
mentioned it during the deep dive that
rapid Pro exposes a comprehensive API
and using the API which is documented
here if you have a rapid for instance
that you're using I think the addresses
you're a patrol instant / v 1 / API or
something like that and that brings you
to the live API Explorer don't quote me
on that might want to go to that
knowledge
is to find that but the API allows you
to get data from your from your surveys
that you've been sending post changes
maybe you want to post some changes to
your contacts or something like that you
can start a flow you can manage your
contacts you can monitor events that are
going on um as a very basic step you can
go to your rabbit pro instance and just
not even thinking about the API just
download your results to a CSV file
which is pretty useful for immediate
results but if you want something that's
going to refresh constantly and you want
to build these you probably want to
think about building a custom dashboard
that accesses your API at cactus we've
done a couple of these we did this one
with these charts here for UNICEF they
were using rapid pro to gather
educational data and to they were
sending out surveys to their teachers to
find out how many students were coming
to their classes each day and what
chapter they were on in the text and
things like that so we used that we
built this data visualization site to
that for them that made these data
points unavailable and charted
numerically this the one on the Left
charted numerically it also allowed you
to filter down to specific groups if you
wanted to only look at this specific
region and then on the right hand side
we've got our map that we built rapid
Pro also allows you on the back end to
add shapes files so on this data
visualization site we connected the
shapes we pulled down the shapes locally
and we said okay now we've got these
shapes how do you want to connect them
to your data so we allow the user to
connect the shapes to groups and then we
display the most common categorical
results within each Pole track pro is
completely open source and available
there track pro uses a local set of the
data so it's constantly running celery
there's actually a celery talk tomorrow
celery is really cool it's using celery
on the back end to poll rapid pro
and keep the poll data and the contact
data and the group data locally so that
it can build these charts really fast
without connecting to the API each time
a different way I don't know if this is
going to work let's see we also for
Python built a custom dashboard we
thought it would be cool to poll people
who came by our booth at PyCon this year
so we built this custom dashboard here
where we just ask them to questions you
know where where did you travel from and
did you travel on a Django pony and they
responded and then we had this nice
little dashboard in this case we didn't
use celery because it was so small so
rather than keep the data locally we do
pull the API continually but we only
refresh the website if there's a new
response so it's a pretty smart website
and it's not even Django it's like even
simpler it's just straight up HTML and
JavaScript that's using a former site
and this side are both using high maps
and high charts and those are really
cool data visualization tools if you're
familiar with them um sooo we're going
to switch back to Rebecca for the
summary text messaging can be a really
cool thing for you to use for data
collection um it can reach people all
around the world pretty simply and
effectively and if you especially if
you're wanting to reach a large and
diverse audience and rapid bro can be a
help with that so you might want to use
rapid pro for your projects um we would
suggest getting started by going to the
community portal reading some of the
documentation seeing how other people
are using it learning about the API um
it's open source if you're interested in
diving into it there is a commercially
hosted version on that you can
experiment with called text it it's
really they give you some free credits
to start with so you can go to text it
that I in build some flows use the
simulator to test it out maybe hook up
to Twitter if you want to try it out
with
friends um and move on beyond that if
you are like with the hooking up to an
SMS gateway if you're looking to get
that out to real users um but at some
point you might decide that you want to
host text it or host rapid row yourself
the words get mixed up sometimes there
are some reasons why you might want to
do that if you have a high volume of
text messages going or messages in
general going in and out text it charges
a pretty notable fee on top of any fees
that you have from your SMS gateway like
twilio um that will add up over time you
might have custom storage needs um
because the commercially hosted version
is a stored on AWS servers in Ireland
which made or might not work for you um
it's also not HIPAA compliant so if you
are storing medical data maybe you need
additional security policies implemented
you also might want custom feature
development the code is open source with
an a GPL license so um you can do that
if you'd like um cactus can help with
that they provide training both for
people building flows and surveys or for
the end users who might take it if you
have a known audience um there is rapid
pro hosting if you'd like to host it um
there you can integrate this data with
an existing external application or
build another one build a new custom
dashboard for your data um so thank you
for yeah I'm please visit us at our
booth today and tomorrow we have some
really cool giveaways and follow us on
twitter at cactus group as we will be
giving away some of mark's mark Lavin's
books i think that's too tomorrow yeah
tomorrow and he'll be signing those and
if you want to learn more about rapid
pro that's the link and we actually
talked really fast so I apologize for
that but it means we have time for
questions all right if you have a
question wait for the microphone so we
can capture it for the video here we go
I really like a lot of what you guys
talked about today I'm curious in a
world that's very concerned about scams
do you encounter any trust issues and
how do you deal with those um a few
answers to that a lot of times the
programs that we've worked with are
working directly with end users in
different ways maybe for example in
Rwanda the healthcare example I gave
where community healthcare workers are
sending data back to the centralized
look or eight organizations the
community health workers are receiving a
lot of information about this program um
not just a random message coming out so
um you might address it in that way
through education of with your users
when you need to um and also a lot of
services like twilio for example um
implement if you if you send the word
stop to a twilio managed SMS gateway
twilio is going to opt out that user
like i can no longer send that user
anything until they allow me to again so
individual users can manage that way
next question and Sue I think you
mentioned a couple aspects of this
already specifically with the API
bringing in data and then I guess
pushing out data as well but I wonder if
you could kind of tie it together for me
thinking of a specific situation where
you've got a customer and you know that
they have a specific set of products
that you have stored in a database
somewhere and you want to ask them what
their experience has been with those
specific products tied to a specific
phone number is that something you could
do and then another push that back in
real time to that database so we have
some sort of tracking of that customers
experience yeah sure so that ties into
the actually the pokémons example so in
that case I think you would just send
the phone number into your API if that's
what you're using as an ID as a sort of
like field to filter out who your look
for and say oh here's the phone number
of the person I want to know the
products that I need to ask them about
and you would need to build that in your
API and then you could call your API
with that API calling action that we
showed on that slide we will make these
slides available later does that answer
your question are no not quite okay okay
just to follow up with as terms of like
Singh the data back with that look sure
yeah you could um yeah I can't I can
imagine that you'd be able to do it both
ways I can't imagine that you wouldn't
be able to call an API with data um I
have we haven't tested that one but I
would imagine you could call your API
with data and save it as well I don't
see why not more questions alright then
everybody thank our speakers